let's go to ben who joins us in
pittsburgh pennsylvania ben how can we
help
all right gentlemen thank you so much
for taking my call you bet
well my question is this uh i'm 27 years
old i live at home
still i'm on baby step two uh the only
debt that i have is my college loans
how much is that um it's about thirty
five thousand dollars
um it's kind of a sticky situation
uh i was at another university before i
transferred to the university that i
graduated with
and after graduating from there i
received a letter from the federal trade
commission
that there was a lawsuit for fraud so
it's kind of being investigated right
now
but essentially enough that's not
actually my my main reason for calling
my my main reason for calling is i've
always been close with my family
um i have six siblings and my my parents
are
very much about helping their kids and
getting them started on their feet right
and
i thank them so much for that however
lately
i've been butting heads with my father
in the sense of
moving out and getting on my own i've
brought up the idea of renting multiple
times to him
and him being a renter himself and has
also had
tenants in houses that he does own he
strongly
persists that i don't do that and insist
that i stay home and save for a house
um i'm kind of looking on some guidance
to see if that's good advice because
i'm not getting any younger you know my
sister's getting married she's moving
out this year my other brother just
bought a house
he's going to be moving out within the
end of the year and i'm kind of stuck
if if i should move out and rent and and
start my life or if i should
ben what do you do what do you do for a
living brother
uh i work in i.t for a university here
close to pittsburgh
what do you make a year uh right now
making 51 000
a year yeah move out tomorrow yeah okay
you're i'm gonna say this as nicely as i
can because i
i trust you that your dad's a good man
and and i love that you are connected as
you are to your family
your 27 year old man making 51 000 a
year your dad didn't get a vote
and if you still owe 35 000 student
loans you're not in a position to buy a
house
and you need to get your debt paid off
and then get a down payment saved up and
get an emergency fund saved up
which you can go buy a cheap one-bedroom
apartment
start having a life start
differentiating yourself from your
family doesn't mean you don't love them
doesn't mean you're not connected to
them but that means that
they're not making decisions for you
because you're 27 year old man
and then you're going to be in a
position to buy a house
down the road you're not that's not you
don't you're not financially ready for
that
right and that's the point that i
brought up to him as a i'm like you know
i could
get married next year i did he just did
another job and move you know like that
that's not an easy thing to do when you
have
let me ask ben a question ben i'm gonna
ask you a question so that you can
answer and my colleague can actually
dive into this
okay i love this tina's both up then
teeing you both
up what's your what's your stomach for
telling dad what john
already told you you already started
coming up with more things feels like
you're just keeping this thing alive
and i want to know stomach uh meaning
you got the guts to look at dad and say
it exactly the way that john
said it is it a one is it a five is it a
ten where is it on a scale of one to ten
one being i'm terrified to do it it
makes me sick to think about it ten
i'm ready to go i just needed permission
um
i would probably say it's about a five
or six yeah i could tell them but you
know
i mean we've been so close to the family
so you look for that approval
wait a second wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait i got one more question
john
do you really think that he's gonna
disown you
no of course he's not but you're acting
like it
i acknowledge john he might be a little
upset and think that think his son is
not being wise are you
are you the oldest i'm the oldest boy
yes i was his first son
so it is always a shock to the system
the first time a grown child
tells their parents i'm grateful for
your advice i'm going east
yeah or i'm going west and that always
sends a shock away through the family
system
it will take some getting used to
because they're not used to this they've
got
six kids the oldest the oldest of which
is almost
30 and they're you're still living at
home as though you were 16.
here's the thing asking your dad the
same advice overnight you know what no
he's going to say
so going back to that and going back to
that is great there needs to be a
transition
from where your parents give you their
thoughts on things
but not the answers on things and this
is your moment
let me tell you let me say this hey ben
i'm going to give enough time for my
colleague to clean this up if i mess
this up but let me tell you what i think
you're going to be right listen ben the
very man
that you are so worried about his
approval
if you don't do this your desire for
approval and love and connection is
going to turn into deep resentment
i'm telling you am i right john and
resentment is the
it's a killer it's the that's right so
if you don't do what john said you're
going to end up resenting your dad
because here's the deal
you're head and heart are clear on what
you need to do you're just worried that
dad's going to be upset with me so take
him out to take him out to a big boy
lunch
you pay oh yeah let him know hey dad i'm
really grateful
but i've decided to move out i'm going
to start my adventure on my own i'm
almost
30 and it's time i'm so grateful for
your help up until now
but it's time for me to move on yep